I want to try this card before it goes
all right all right
I'll be the first go on I can already
see this will be the most replayed part
of the episode I just wanna I just wanna
I'll take one little
test bro that looks viscous can we get
some spoons oh my God it smells oh smell
that oh my god dude why is it so thick
oh my God that's like a paste
that's crazy I mean
I'm very excited for this at all do we
have any milk that's fine it's fine I'm
sure no it won't I'm sure I'm gonna die
joe he's just not going to uh talk you
guys go first I'm just try this real
quick I'm gonna try a little bit all
right all right all right
that's all right I'll deal with water
how is it
um
it's not that bad actually is it not I
don't I I I do not trust these to his
opinion the thing about like actually
it's not it's not as bad as 10. I
remember 10 being worse the thing about
the thing about this is that a few bites
isn't too bad but it's when you have
like the whole thing that you start I
can smell that [__] hell I can
literally see like the uh curry powder
it's it's more powder than Curry man
they're like they're like salt grains or
curry powder in there
it's a little it's not awful the time
when I had yesterday was worse genuinely
it's not that bad you could do this you
could do this all right
the one bites not that bad one bite
isn't that bad it's when you have an
entire and it's going down your throat
and I work inside edition
yeah no worries
I think it's like more peppery than it
is like yeah spicy you know
I mean it's definitely spicy don't get
me wrong it's spicy
I'm sweating a little bit
it's very peppery yeah yeah that's
that's it right yeah peppery kind of
spicy
being an adult is enjoying pepper at the
salt and pepper
spicy that's spicy it's not that bad
though it's it's bad as 10. I've never
had teams so I don't know
it's pretty uh I mean I didn't actually
make a video a whole video about eating
10 and yeah I didn't [__] eat it it
was like a 12 minute video about how bad
it was I don't think it was that bad
yeah but she can't eat level one oh okay
she's Filipino she doesn't eat spicy
food but that's I can't do that with
oranges in the video I'm like Ben tries
Orange from Florida okay to be fair I
think because I've trained myself now in
the past couple years on that I've
that's not as bad as I thought it was
gonna be that's not bad it hurts but I
can deal with it that is the kind of
spice I don't like that's the that
that's so much like artificial spice
give me like a good Pepper Peppers the
chai Peppers when I see them they strike
fear of me oh I know my digestive system
is going to be [__] the next day I've
been I've been I've had I've [__] four
times today already
like okay so I'm sweating I guess go go
this can be an interesting being an
adult is being able to know that you're
gonna regret a decision and still make
it when uh yeah I'm leaving that right
now if if or when you eventually have
kids would you try to give your kids
like would you try to make it so they
don't grow up too fast either or you
know they kind of have like
the chart like what is like a good
childhood you know what is a good
childhood that uh aside from obviously
just being in a good position uh having
Rich parents
being a nappo baby yeah no I don't know
I think I think it's the idea of you
know I would say I had a pretty good
childhood
um not because like my parents were like
well off or like you know I was like
[__] privileged or whatever you know
yeah that's all dependent on perspective
but like I think the one thing that made
my childhood really good was that my
parents were like open enough and were
understanding enough for me to be able
to pursue what I wanted to do yeah or
like pursue like even if it was like
[__] insignificant even if it was
something like uh you know hey Dad I
want to start playing tennis yeah you
know or like I want to learn how to play
the piano no son you shall not play
tennis yeah you know or it's like any
kind of like thing where it's like you
know I want to be I want to like learn
how to do this or like learn this skill
or be able to do this or play you know
this thing and as long as it wasn't like
too [__] extreme like you know if if
I was 11 years old and I was like Dad I
want to skydive he'd just be like you're
you're on crack you know you know I'm
not gonna let you do that but you know
if it was just like you know like
childhood uh you know I guess
discoveries of like you know certain
things you want to do or certain uh
skills you want to try I think a good
childhood is having those parents that
just let you do it yeah and you know
being like all right we'll let you do it
if you don't end up liking it that's
totally fine if you end up liking it hey
good for you I think it's just having
that option open yeah you know because
there's a lot of like controlling
parents out there you will do exactly
this and this and this yeah they're so
tired of me swapping Hobbies all the
time oh so they're like [__] sake pick
something yeah we just pick something
and stick with it for [__] sake that's
why it's in my parents it's a [__]
miracle I've done YouTube for 10 years
because they thought for sure I was
gonna get bored of it I know what I
liked right it's not going to compromise
yeah if I didn't want if I thought I
liked [__] playing badminton and I
thought it sucked afterwards like I had
hobbies that lasted like not even a week
but it's the fact I think that my
parents let me discover for myself
whether it was something I actually
wanted to do or not defines a good
childhood but I guess that's also like I
guess that is that's not my privilege
but also obviously it'd be a bit well
off to allow to pay for your kids to do
this kind of stuff because oh yeah you
know nowadays I feel like this it's a
lot harder to be like hey yeah I can I
can afford to give you piano lessons
that are probably never gonna come to
anything and I mean mind you there were
some there were some things as well that
I was like Hey I want to do this thing
and my parents were just like we don't
have the money for that fair enough yeah
so like they were fair about it you know
so they obviously saw they were like all
right is it financially viable
I bought a [__] Mario the theme song
for my phone yeah it broke
no pialysis [__] you Jerry my dad always
used to say like I'm putting that on the
tab yeah but waiting for when you have
to pay me back as an adult every time I
was like Dad can I buy this like candy
and he's just like how much is it he
looks and he's like all right I'm
putting it on the tab and so as a kid I
did I'll start I had this like [__]
IOU that my dad was like keeping track
of being like I was just prepared for
when I turned 18 for my dad just be like
happy 18th birthday it's kind of cool
the nose how much money your parents
have spent on you yeah no just out of no
for no reason just no reason just to see
a number that was like this is how much
we spoke I mean it would give me a good
idea of how much I have to spend on my
kid right so I thought you better say
pay them back but you're like no [__]
them I am the gift Joe finishes
University and he gets the student loan
and his dad comes along he's like this
is the real load yeah this is
can you Google what's the average amount
parents spend on their kids in their
entire like life I'm sure because I know
this I remember there's a figure like 10
years ago but 10 years is nothing others
are watching this thing and like you
know when you watch things and they
mention like money and then like in
today's money it's this yeah yeah and
then you're like oh man that's crazy
that's so long ago and you're like it's
only 100 years ago you're like oh [__]
wait I'll be alive for like most of that
yeah so my money could go from being
like nothing to something if I if I just
held on to it oh yeah that's literally
every person who like bought a house
like that's like your parents your
grandparents ages like we bought this
[__] seven bedroom full bathroom
Mansion for like twenty thousand dollars
and it's like today it's like oh I can
buy a shoebox for 1.5 million that's
just every American realizing how young
their country is yeah and uh how how
much of their lifetime they've already I
mean I get it Australia was the exact
same thing bro yeah
or one child all right for one
I've got three brothers
future future my future shout if you're
watching this I expect the 300K back by
the time yeah I'm gonna write it I'm
gonna actually start a test
I I did often wish my dad actually kept
the time so that as an adult I could be
like all right let me see how much it
would be super interesting and hindsight
to be like we spent how much on this
weird hobby for you yeah I'm sure people
don't keep track right I I just just
because I love looking at numbers and
it's so fun seeing data yeah like all
line bro I went to piano lessons for
like 15 years I don't want to think
about how much money my parents did you
choose to do piano lessons or did you I
did so how it ended up happening was who
uh my sister was actually the one who
was like I want to learn how to play
piano and you know my mom was always
like you know I've been the Asian parent
she was always like Oh My My Asian child
wants to learn an instrument and it's
piano Destiny so we bought like an
upright piano for the house right and my
sister was like learning how to play at
this point I hadn't started at all my
sister I would just watch my sister like
practicing and kind of struggle because
I guess piano wasn't really a thing and
then I would jump on the piano and I
would without any lessons just be able
to play the exact same thing my sister
was he's a savant
and then that's what my parents are like
I think we should get you in instead of
my system so my sister immediately quit
after that and then I filled her place
right and then I did it for 15 years so
it's like my parents my parents are
probably thinking like oh thank God the
investment on that piano didn't go to
waste because if I had never picked it
up and my sister would have quit then we
would have just had a [__] dust
dust-filled piano just in our house but
fair enough it was actually put to good
use thankful